ah mais si Madonna c'est la fille qui a
des tresses c'est une grosse bouche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Madonna le Queen of Pop est à Los
Angeles le 5 février dernier pour
assister au Gremy Award et c'est très
son apparence à quelques peu éclipser le
reste elle est arrivée regardez mais
regardez
[Musique]
de ce qu'on appelle des fils tenseurs
qui malheureusement se sont épaissi sous
sa peau et du coup on fait cette espèce
de grosse pommettes énorme que
normalement on devrait faire alors on
explique pour les gens que c'est les
nouveaux liftings non je te fais passer
des fils qui tirent un peu le
surement tout elle en a mis dans les
pommettes elle en a mis en haut donc
malheureusement ça épaissi toute sa peau
et elle a un petit peu une peau de
rhinocérosction
extrêmement triste à propos de Madonna
je discutais avec trois gamines de 3e
les stages de 3e elle connaissait pas
Madonna elle connaissait pas Mylène
Farmer et elle connaissait pas Céline
Dion et tout d'un coup il y en a une qui
me dit ah mais si Madonna c'est la fille
qui a des tresses c'est une grosse
bouche
pour elle ça n'était que ça et très
c'est une grosse bouche exactement cette
image mais qu'est-ce que ça peut en fait
envie de le faire
aux gens moi par exemple quand je
regarde quand je
regarde je regarde machin etc et temps
je vois des filles qui font des trucs je
me dis bon là le string c'est un peu
tout moche la tenue c'est un peu je le
pense mais est-ce que je vais l'écrire
qu'est-ce que ça peut faire en fait
quand elle fait à son visage selon les
chirurgiens alors Botox acide
hyaluronique l'élève plus fine paupières
légèrement tombante elle a fait du
collagène elle s'est littéralement
enfilée des centaines de fils d'acide
polyclactique sous la peau c'est celui
qui consiste à considérer consolider la
structure et créer du volume
elle c'est un métier sans problème
c'est que son image va être commentée
c'est comme ça toute sa vie à la bande
de son image pour pouvoir vivre et
exister donc au bout d'un moment faut
assumer moi le premier je vends mon
image à la télé je fais de la chirurgie
j'assume on me dit oui tête de Bogdanov
tout ce que tu veux c'est le jeu c'est
le prix à payer c'est comme ça il y a un
biopic sur elle qui a été annulé
voilà reprendre quand elle aura surprise
là parce qu'elle tient vraiment à tout
faire de A à Z ils ont déjà trouvé
l'actrice c'est et tu sais pourquoi ça a
été annulé parce qu'elle voulait faire
elle-même toutes les années de sa vie
maintenant
quoi
bonsoir à toutes et à tous on traite
saison la nouvelle star a révélé de
nombreux talents qui sont aujourd'hui
des artistes incontournables de la scène
musicale française comme Christophe
Willem Amel Bent ou encore Julien Doré
c'est pas ma faute
[Musique]
mais sur le plateau cette semaine
certains artistes étaient bizarrement
absents alors que la chaîne avait
communiqué sureau dans la bande-annonce
en effet pas de Cindy Sanders ou de
Xavier Mathew le gagnant de la dernière
saison sur scène est-ce que ça va bouger
surfends à fond sur la nostalgie le
programme n'a pourtant convaincu qu'a
peine de millions de téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
puisque j'arrive au casting on me fait
doubler une file d'attente de 8 heures
parce que j'ai le physique qu'ils ont
envie ils ont des critères ensuite on me
ramène on me dit voilà non non il faut
pas chanter ça et ça il faut faire un
medley il faut faire des caisses il faut
faire beaucoup de mouvements ce que je
fais et en fin de compte on fait venir
des caméras là le lendemain chez moi en
organisent un concert qui n'a pas lieu
du tout on ne fait croire que je suis
vraiment la gagnante de de cette
émission jusqu'au bout et encore avant
de rentrer en plateau me dit Cindy on
sait ce que la production cherche
faisant des caisses c'est toi la
Nouvelle Star cette année aujourd'hui je
suis venue pour clôturer le sujet parce
que on est beaucoup concerné par rapport
à la nouvelle star à avoir souffert il y
a beaucoup de gens qui ont fait ce
casting et qui malheureusement ben on
finit très très mal heureusement que moi
j'étais très bien entourée donc c'est
pour ça que je suis là aujourd'hui pour
faire comprendre aux gens que la télé
reste la arrêtez d'écouter et de croire
tout ce qu'on vous dit arrêtez de vous
arrêter à ça parce qu'il y a des gens
derrière comme nous des humains qui
souffrant moi j'ai souffert pendant
pendant presque 15 ans heureusement que
mon mari était là et mon fils parce que
pour moi c'était très dur d'entendre et
de voir des gens me dire tu es qu'une
grosse merde va te faire tuer des
injures mais pas possible
[Musique]
les personnalités ont telle raison de
parler de leur démon Plaza il dit qu'il
en est à 200 jours sans alcool il a
craqué une fois à Noël Bigard nous
annonçait aussi les jours il compte il
compte en permanence donc comme ça faire
une déclaration sur une addiction ou sur
un problème
qui peut parfois amener à une certaine
déchéance et tout je trouve que ça c'est
un petit peu trop brutal frontal et je
trouve ça casse un peu le rêve non moi
je dis non parce que c'est pareil comme
Natacha je trouve que ça abîme l'image
de l'artiste après on l'a vite que pour
ça et après c'est la porte ouverte à ce
que vous voulez une fois que l'artiste
se dit maintenant on sait que je suis
drogué et bourré je peux le faire quand
je veux de toute façon c'est comme ça je
suis malade alors que quand on regarde
pour nous on le dit pas on essaie d'être
un maximum clean quand on se présente
dans des endroits au contraire tu vois
forcément ou tu le dis tu parles des
addictions et tu dis que tu as décidé
d'arrêter que tu veux t'en sortir du
coup tu prends un engagement public de
vos amis
le fait que tu t'engages et ben je
trouve ça te force un peu à te voir
tu t'es engagé et bah tu dis merde
c'est la chute de l'artiste à chaque
fois qu'il y a des images dégueulasses
et bien sûr à chaque fois qu'ils ont des
problèmes de drogue ou d'alcool
qu'est-ce qu'on attend les reportages et
il en est où est-ce qu'il va aller
oui oui puis surtout j'ai envie de dire
c'est souvent lire un processus
psychologique de ces artistes mais si tu
as envie d'en parler c'est pas
simplement parce que un journaliste pose
la question mais en vrai c'est parce que
ça correspond à un truc ok je le dis
aujourd'hui et j'en parle